- [Narrator] Juul Labs was once
one of the most valuable
startups in the world,
valued in 2018 at $38 billion.
But most of that has gone up in smoke.
In 2020, Altria, which holds
a 35% stake in the company
said Juul is now worth
less than $5 billion.
- Juul's been a fascinating story to cover
because it rose and fell so quickly.
It really turned the tobacco
industry upside down overnight.
- [Narrator] Juul is
fighting for its life,
laying off in the past year
around 3/4 of its employees.
It faces hundreds of lawsuits
alleging the company marketed
its products to teens.
- If you think you can
come into this county
and you can harm our youth
and we're not gonna fight
you back, you're wrong.
- [Narrator] It's product's
popularity with young people
has become the liability
that's a threat to the
company's viability.
In 2015, Juul introduced a new vaporizer.
The company was founded
by Stanford University graduate students
Adam Bowen, and James Monsees.
- Adam and I smoked.
We tried to quit and we failed.
For us, giving up smoking
required an alternative which
did not exist at the time.
We founded Juul Labs to invent one.
- Adam Bowen and James
Monsees developed a product
that was unlike any e-cigarette
that came before it.
It had a cool, sleek, slim design
that looked like a USB flash drive,
and they were going for an
aesthetic like an Apple product.
They wanted to have something
that was high tech, cool,
that people would wanna be seen holding.
The secret sauce was
also what was inside it.
It contained a nicotine salt solution
that delivered a really
powerful punch of nicotine,
but without the throat harshness
that you might otherwise expect
from an e-cigarette at the time.
- [Narrator] In 2016,
legacy tobacco firms,
with their similar looking products,
led the pack in e-cigarette sales.
That year, Juul sold 2.2 million devices.
It was still a small player.
But in 2017, that changed.
Juul's sales numbers soared that year,
increasing nearly eight fold.
- It was available in
more and more stores,
many convenience stores and gas stations.
So that helped propel its growth
and Juul also marketed it.
They gave Juul packages to celebrities
for as little as a dollar
to try to get them to use
it and be seen using it
in the hopes that celebrities
and other social media influencers
would help spread the word.
- [Narrator] As Juul's own
data would later disclose,
some of the customers its
product was attracting
had never smoked cigarettes before.
By the end of 2018, Juul Labs had captured
68% of the $1.9 billion
US e-cigarette market.
Prominent investors took notice.
A fundraising round that summer
brought the startup's
value to about $16 billion.
But 2018 was also the
year Juul found itself
in the crosshairs of regulators.
The Food and Drug Administration
opened an investigation into Juul
after parents and school administrators
sounded the alarm about youth vaping.
After two decades of declining
teen cigarette smoking,
a 2018 survey revealed that
the share of high schoolers
who were vaping had
increased significantly.
- When the regulator in charge
of the e-cigarette industry
targets your company, that's a big deal.
And Juul took a series of steps that year
to try to show that they were
taking the problem seriously.
The first thing they did
was they said that they
would work with retailers
to ensure that at the point of sale
kids weren't getting access to
Juul and other e-cigarettes.
- [Narrator] But the FDA wasn't satisfied.
It conducted an inspection
at the company's headquarters
and the agency threatened to
take flavored e-cigarettes
off the market entirely
because they were
attracting underage users.
- Juul responded by voluntarily pulling
most of their sweet and fruity flavors
out of brick and mortar retail stores.
So those flavors included Mango Cucumber
and Creme Brulee, for example.
Juul also suspended its social
media marketing in the US.
- [Narrator] Despite all this,
Juul's valuation soared to $38 billion
when Altria, the maker of Marlboro,
bought a significant minority
stake in the company.
- Altria wanted to get a piece
of the growing e-cigarette market
and Altria's own e-cigarette products
were not that successful.
- [Narrator] Altria got in
at an inauspicious moment.
After making the nearly $13
billion investment in Juul,
things began to unwind.
Rite Aid, the third
largest us pharmacy chain,
announced it would stop selling
e-cigarettes in its stores.
In September 2019, Juul CEO
Kevin Burns stepped down.
He was replaced by Altria
executive K.C. Crosthwaite.
That same month,
in a blow to the company's
overseas ambitions,
China, the world's biggest tobacco market,
halted Juul's sales just
days after its launch there.
And in the US, governors
called for immediate bans
on all flavored e-cigarettes.
- Common sense says if you
don't know what you are smoking,
don't smoke it.
- [Narrator] At the same time,
the entire nicotine vaping industry
faced a full blown PR crisis.
- New vaping numbers.
Illnesses top 1,000
with deaths on the rise.
- Some patients actually
suffered toxic chemical burns
to their lungs and airways,
as if being exposed to a chemical spill.
- [Narrator] After hospitals
throughout the country
linked at least eight deaths to vaping,
US health officials urged Americans
to stop using any and
all e-cigarette products
while authorities investigated the cause.
The illnesses were eventually linked
to marijuana vaping devices
containing vitamin E oil,
not to e-cigarettes like Juul,
but the damage to vaping's
image continued to be felt
and the tsunami of bad
news for Juul continued.
Juul's new CEO halted most US advertising,
then stopped all US sales
of Juul's sweet and fruity flavors.
State attorneys general across the country
sued Juul for deceptive
marketing of its products.
- Juul basically took a page
from big tobacco's playbook
by marketing its products
in a manner that was
appealing to underage youth.
- [Narrator] In court
filings, experts alleged
that even though the models Juul used
in its 2015 promotional
materials were in their 20s,
they appeared in poses and behaviors
more characteristic of underage
teens than mature adults.
Crosthwaite was grilled by lawmakers
for the marketing methods Juul
employed before he arrived.
- We are focused on
combating underage access.
'Cause it know it puts it all at risk
if we don't make progress here.
- Sir, how do I trust
what you say? (scoffs)
- My actions, so far since I've joined,
support our recognition
that more needed to be done.
- [Narrator] More done with fewer people.
Amid a sharp drop in
sales in the fall of 2020,
Juul continued to shrink its workforce
down to around 1,000 from
its high of just over 4,000
and pulled out of most overseas markets.
And Altria wrote down the
value of its stake in Juul
by around $11 billion.
- Everything hinges on an FDA review
that will determine whether
or not Juul's products
can stay on the market or
whether they have to come off.
It presented a real potential
for a public health benefit.
You know, getting adult cigarette smokers
off of cigarettes, which
kill 480,000 people a year,
you know, offered a lot of promise.
It was interesting to investors,
it was compelling to
public health experts,
but at the same time, Juul
presented an incredible risk.
- [Narrator] Federal data now show
that youth vaping is decreasing.
The CEO said Juul is now focused
on its founding principle,
to help smokers move away from cigarettes.
But that Juul needs to
prove it can be trusted.
If it can do that, Crosthwaite said,
Juul has a lot of
potential in the longterm.
But that will be an uphill battle.
(intense music)